nearly a month after a wrongful death
lawsuit was filed the attorney
representing detective Justin Terry's
family speaking directly to eight news
now good evening to you at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus I'm Denise Valdez Terry was
killed last June after a steel
construction beam fell on his unmarked
police car in the Northwest part of the
valley Sasha Loftus spoke with that
attorney tonight and joins us live with
more on the case
Denise and Brian this is the part of the
highway where Justin Terry was killed
last June now the attorney representing
detective Justin Terry's family says
while nothing can bring him back this is
a way for them to get closure and the
answers they need
totally preventable
tragedy nine months after the tragic
death of Metro detective Justin Terry
the attorney representing his family
speaks on the action they're taking it's
right on top of where where the driver
would be Terry was killed last June when
a tractor-trailer hit a metal warning
beat in a construction zone on the us-95
near Centennial Parkway that then fell
on his car the case has been filed Brian
paintish who's leading the wrongful
death lawsuit filed by the Terry family
shared more on what they're hoping to
achieve just to compensate the victims
for what they've lost
but also to try to get some closure to
get some answers it names Las Vegas
Paving Company general manager for the
Centennial bull project claiming it was
negligent and
and didn't give drivers enough warning
Western States Contracting and the
driver of the tractor-trailer are also
named in the suit claiming both were
negligent by knowingly carrying an
oversized load on the highway well one
of the goals is to prevent this to get
the word out to stop this type of
conduct from occurring paintish says he
hopes this case also has the power to
make change and protect others from
similar situations so another family
doesn't have to endure what they're
going through
now I did reach out to both companies
named in this lawsuit tonight and did
not hear back in time for this newscast
I also did speak to penish asking him
about how much the Terry family is
seeking in Damages he said while an
exact amount is not set yet that it will
be a substantial amount of money
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now